Heybahdeebeedoh
Uh OH
Heybahdee-- woah...
What the heck is going on with that?
AAAAH!
Why's it so slow?
Ahh!
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to...
Uh
Playerunknown's Battlegrounds
I seem to be experiencing some technical difficulties in terms of-
Oh
Th- That's better all of a sudden?
Is it working?
*mark looks at the abyss*
Is it- Wor- Is- I- It's-  It's working?
YEEES?
*Mark stares into the darkness once again*
Hang on a second, let me see something
(markipliers opening repeats)
Yeah! Seems fine! I guess- I guess it's okay
Maybe it's alright, maybe it's not, I have no idea but either way you guys are here-
And enjoying this stream-
Oh my god
What?
HAEJAAAEH
Okay, I'm trusting it!
I'm believing in it!
I'm believing in the heart of the cards | What?
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Playerunknown's Battlegrounds"
Sooo, if it is being all sorts of broken, then you guys will let me know very soon-
But if it is not
Then I'm just gonna get back into the game here
And uh
We-we'll see what's going on. So...
OH
No? Yes?
There we go, yeah it's fine
IT'S FINE
Hi, guys
So...
Welcome to this ol' yonder stream as many of you may noticed....
I was missing yesterday........
I was just *POOOF*
Gone from the face of YouTube. I was just...
NOWHERE to be found, everyone was searching high and low for where I was but alas.....
I was untraceable, unfindable in the entirety of YouTube no one could find...
Where I was and who I was and where I who was and who did what I know *GASP*
Where that was....
So, with that being said
I... uh...
I have...
An explanation for you, uh of some sort....
I think there's still just a lil - the camera is laggy a little bit and I have no idea why there is
Why is that?
That shouldn't be that way
But, it is
And I don't know
I'm gonna find out why
Buuuuuuut why is that happening?
Hang on
*CLEK*
Oooooh I shoulda tested it huh
Okay, give me one second
Oooooone s-
Times up
Hi
Hello | Hi..?
Can you all hear me?
Huh?
whA?
I don't know what you're talking about. I was never gone in the first place. Don't know what in the world you're talking about so, hello!
Hi
My name is Markiplier, let me know if you guys can see me again
OH, you can!?!
A little bit?
Oh, hi guys. Yes
So I'm back, I have to fix a problem there
Oh
Oh no
Do I agree?
*laughs* Ge-get out of here
Get out of here with that noise
I didn't even know that was possible to invite someone who is not a friend | so rude mark
How do I change that
I don't have any friends | That's your fault, you could've had one
I fly solo my entire life
No one even knows who I am | Say that to your fan base
No one can know who I am
Alright so whatever
Just gonna refuse that one | double rejection
Alright I'm gonna get into the game because
I don't wanna play with nobody here
So, I uhhhhh
I have a little bit of an explanation to give for yesterday, umm
It's - nothing terrible happened, like don't - no - everyone has seemed to be worried that
OH MY GOD he's taking a day off!!!
Everything must be horrible in his life
But in reality
Uh that is not the case - hello
Lag
There we go I'm in
Uh hi
I'm the world's greatest Markiplier fan
Does anybody else want to join me on the adventure? | I thought you flew solo
So
With yesterday, I took a little bit of a breather because
I was getting frustrated and not frustrated with making videos I don't want anyone to think that
I was frustrated with trying to do everything all at once and that
Was like the key source of all my frustration cause...
In - I-in my ambition, and I have a lot of ambition
*get's distracted* Oh you wanna try to fight me? Huh? HUH?
The naked Markiplier fan's gonna fight all a you
But in my ambition to uh do everything
It ended up so that I was able to do nothing and so I was getting so frustrated with trying to...
Be the best that I could be at everything that I didn't actually do anything
You what tha-that juxtaposition there's so many opportunities
For you to do stuff
And your inability to capture them
You know, uh... It just ends up so frustrating so the day before yesterday
Got really frustrated and I was just like
Man there's so much that I want to do I just feel - I feel like
I can't focus on any one thing because there's so many different things that I have to focus on
Why are we on fire already?
*giggles*
This doesn't seem right | I see nothing wrong :D
Hang on a second I think there's something wrong
Hello??
*inaudible video game radio mumbling*
Ah yeah okay
Habadabada
Alright whatever
So if you don't know about this game you
You - you *giggles again* airdrop into a death zone
And then you gotta find guns, Day Z style and kill each other | Day Z style? So running around for an hour for nothing?
That's what I'm gonna be doing as I try to focus on talking about what the hell I'm talking about - which isn't a whole lot
But
That being said
*groans melodically*
haaAAAAABOOSKIE
Okay there I go - HOOOAAAAAA
So *giggles again* I must be so cold | Nah
Alright, I'm gonna go over this way
I've only played this a few times and I'm not particularly good at it
I tried to record an episode but the recording failed so it's even a wonder that it's working here
But either way
I got frustrated
With not being able to do anything so
I took yesterday as like a reset day
When I said I was taking a break I wasn't actually taking a break
I actually worked out a whole lot
I-I I focused on
Uh... writing a list of goals, trying to identify what exactly I wanted to do
With my life and what exactly I wanted to do with umm...
Like what I was doing on YouTube and the future after YouTube and stuff like that and so
It was just really nice
To be able to kind of focus on that idea
And so that's what I did and it was really nice because it let me
Like it let me really really really get a reset
And I actually intended to post videos yesterday but I was so um... | Damn mark, hittin' the ground running... Quite literally.
Holy shit magic
I was so preoccupied with like my planning and what not that it actually ended up
That uh... I just kept the day off and...
I don't know it was just really good to have a soft reset
On, you know
What I was doing and so when I took a break it was more of a mental vacation
Focusing on the things and also narrowing down
Is this pants? PANTS?!
What is this pants bullshit?!?
Smoke grenades *giggles*
Yeah that's gonna help me
Hey anybody wanna get smoked up? | Yeah sure, free Wednesday?
Huh?
Anyone wanna smoke me up? Huh?
Nobody?
Okay
No guns, huh?
No guns?
Nah? Nothin?
I got a greNADE *derpy derp*
I got smoke grenades and that's all I got, no one better mess with me!
Imma smoke the shit out of them
Okay I guess I can't hop that - there we go
So yeah I took yesterday as a reset and I went missing and lot of people were worried but there was no reason
To worry because in all honesty
Oh good, more smoke grenades!
Ah, that's gonna help me!
Ah that gonna really- was that a gas can or something?
Nah, its nothing useable.
Welll this ain't good...
Hmm
Got a whole lot of nothing here- Ooh, a helmet!
I got pants and a helmet.
Hoho right
I am unstopable.
Alright, anything over here?
See, I don't know, uh, I dont know any of  the spawn layouts or
anything like that I don't know if there are certain rules
for where things can only spawn in certain places
but I'm probably going to get blasted
Into
Kingdom come eventually here.
BUT I got nothing so I'm just gonna y'know
Wander...
Aimlessly...
Without guns or anything that can help me...
Cause I'm a helpless baby.
Alright
I got a smoke grenade. I'm gonna throw a smoke grenade!
Fire in the hoolllee!!
No one's going to know where I am now, they're gonna be looking at all the smoke!
*Markimoo laughs like a mad man*
My master plan has finally come to fruition...
WELP
I'm the shirtless wanderer.
Wandering the streets of this broken city.
And I'm gonna die real hard.
At least I'm in the circle!
That's awefully nice.
I bet theres gonna be a bunch of people in this c- ooh is that a jeep over there
Oh, thought I saw a vehicle
After I clear this- uh oh, red zone has started
Ooooh, I'm not near that so I don't need to worry about it.
Alright wadda we got
boodliy doop bu do do do doop
hope no one shoots me in the face
woop boop shu-boop boop
ah bup badah (why do you make my life harder markimoo?) budup boop
Anybody home?-Anybody home?
Anybody wanna get in a fist fight?
I got grenades, I got nothing else
I got hope in my heart
But that's it
hope don't get you stop from being shot
That only took 20 minutes... Thanks mark...
uuuh hmm
Whole lot of nothin' eh? (When did you become Canadian?)
Whole lot of nothin'
huh..?
Is that what I got prescribed ' ere?
Whole lota' dick-diddly?
A'got alota' dick-diddly doo da- OO!
Well that's handy
Well I'll take that
*markimoo's b00tiful mating call*
Alright how do I-? 'Ang on
Gonna reload this bad boy 'ere
ALRIGHT! So.
Markimoo found a gunny-woo
And mirkimoo's not gonna use it effectively no matter what markimoo do
So markimoo-
Restricting the play area
Nah! We're good! We 're fine
Did I see someone stupid stepping?
Someone stupid stepping over in my town?!
Huh
Here I
Going for the next one
Anybody in here?
Hello?
Baelor?
Anybody?
No open doors
Either someone's very tiny about closing the door behind them and there's no one here
Well see if I-
Ooh Baseball cap
Naah! I dont want *laugh*